questa è la cosa più pesante che io
abbia mai mangiato in tutta la mia vita
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata ora buone
fatte feste come suggeriva graziana che
dubito sia italiano proprio il generale
ma comunque spero che abbiate passato in
maniera positiva
spero che da quando ho registrato questo
video quando uscirà non ci siano state
delle catastrofi per cui questo video
sembra fuori luogo ma vorrei corner e
contagiante mi avere il nuovo picco di
contagi e restano alti comunque ieri è
stata l'anniversario della nascita di
elvis presley re del rock tutto quello
che vi pare ma sulla morte di elvis
presley invece ci sono un sacco di
teorie di leggende alcune estremamente
interessante rho tra le varie cose che
abbiamo trovato uno in particolare
secondo me è perfetta per cucina buttata
perché tra le cause della morte di elvis
presley dicono alcune persone che si è
stato ucciso da un panino il suo panino
preferito che praticamente si sfondava
mattina avrà anso cena sempre romagna va
il fool's gold
rinominato l'oro del mart o si dice
proprio legato al fatto che questa
specie di bomba calorica col tempo hanno
in qualche modo fatto del male proprio
alla sua salute e l'abbia portato poi ad
avere un arresto cardiaco ma finché non
uscirà il 2027 una nuova verità una
busta shock ulteriore ad allora addio
l'idea del panino assassino è quella che
voglio sposare per cui oggi faremo il
panino che ha ucciso il dis presley
[Musica]
ragazzi siamo pronti abbiamo scaldato le
natiche
io direi a questo punto di andare con
gli ingredienti ma prima facciamo
entrare l'ingrediente principale è il
vis presley
sembri una un anno netta che fa jogging
puoi guardare di là cioè a parte che
degli occhiali con quest ambiente ed è
bellissimo perché posso staccarti questo
coso questa è la garanzia per far capire
che sono originali tu hai detto che io
sono morto adesso c'è 87 anni quindi ho
avuto tempo per studiare altre canzoni
le lingue per passate un po a questi
nuovi cantanti
ma sono venuto qui per mangiare e per
farmi sapere se il panino che faremo
insieme è esattamente quello che è lo
stesso che mi faceva la vecchia utri
potri audrey la ristoratrice parto ci
sono stato io in questo in questo bar
angeli neri in francia
comunque passiamo agli ingredienti per
fare i fool's gold avremo bisogno di due
fette di pane mezzo vasetto di burro
d'arachidi 8 fette di bacon due banane
così una vera un quarto di barattolo di
miele e pura volontà ragazzi il vizio il
passo che mi ha reso parlato
mi sembra la base di essere a quella
l'ho scritta io la
mamma può sentire le note del re del
rock
sembra un parto enrico costa cambia su
una visita dalla ginecologa
ad ora
questo non è un ballo qualsiasi adesso
qui è in ballo di ervis dal dis presley
se possiamo tirare o un certo languorino
allora oggi noi andiamo a fare un
qualcosa che veramente fa male posso
dire però io li al ristorante con cucina
vaud ha quindi con fare tutto io e tu
cosa farai semplicemente
la bellezza di 42 mila chilocalorie ma
non è possibile che ce l'abbia 40 2003
allora semplici per
[Musica]
gli aiuti non c'è niente qui prova a
chiederlo brocco alcol mio passo vi
serve un tagliere mi serve anche un
piatto oltre ai perfetto allora prima
cosa che facciamo è bacon bello
croccante non è che abbiamo dei sergi
lardo del bacon in italia li chiamiamo
scar ex una mano enrico ma infatti ma
dividetevi con lui stamani sta facendo
jogging
vuoi vedere come come veder rom
io poi colpi che hai presente per
esempio quel quel signorotto come si
chiama gam style
[Musica]
puoi levare dal padiglione
ragazze una gamma incredibile di nuovo
questa parrucca di elvis che gli ultimi
nei commenti che mi sembra questa
persona vogliamo dare un indizio
mamma mia ti prego non ti va di mentone
testa come barba aveva
in qualche modo
di imporre
con calma cerchiamo di capire
in cosa consiste questo panino
belli i
ragazzi burro morbido una quantità
generosa e se palma
questa roba è assurda fino a un certo
punto no non è assurdo adesso per voi
questo tempo in questa epoca questo l'ho
inventata io adesso basta testata se
l'utile che vita 12 del 9 quest'anno
inventato legno
fondamentale a questo punto è prendere
le fette di pane è però vincolato so
dire buono c'era preparata ma se tu
veramente togli i crudi e tutto
veramente buono e da qui guarda vieni a
vedere qui c'è il burro è entrato dentro
parlare questa sbotta
come si dice imburrato ragazzi sono già
un po disgustato ma ciò che sta per
arrivare supererà di gran lunga la
vostra fantasia immaginazione prima casa
a infilare sono due strati di
burro d'arachidi o questa colazione
tutte le volte con la zona mamma mia
io quello di loro inizia a spalmare se
lo fanno a casa di prevot anca temi su
instagram devo vedere voi che lo fate
possiamo mettere un like a enrico che si
è prestato di vestirsi così dunque
parlate molto di questo enrico deve
essere una persona per cui se hai capito
era uno che tossiva ogni 4 minuti poi da
quando è andato in video ha smesso di
tossire abbiamo fatto questo cosa ci fa
dopo un papà nando lo posso suggerire il
tagliarle a rondelle leggermente
inclinate ma qual è la tua canzone
preferita
fa sapere mia
dico in generale
nella storia del 2021 2021
dovrei avere all'anno scorso
certo
mentre si continua a tagliare io vado a
posizionare intanto le fettine di pane
jos vado a mettere adesso c'è lo step
successivo che quello di aggiungere il
miele andiamo con il kuk no a fare
questo disgustoso step successivo 4
fette di baker
c'è un altro passaggio anche se manca un
altro strato che unisce
metto di fiocchetti così almeno è più
facile poi chiuderlo perché spalmarlo è
veramente impossibile no io non ci credo
non c'è dicevo le vediamo poi quando lo
mangi però è lì che vi voglio vedere
oggettivamente correndo che ci sarà un
motivo perché è morto a 40 anni lasciò a
questo punto parte un po difficile anche
una tecnica si ve lo faccio vedere pay
attention and andate su spotify a
sentire le mie canzoni e il canale di
questo poveraccio qual è la tecnica
messo bene bravo o capitino capitolo
star agata è pronta da ragazzi non è
pronta perché bisogna fare un ultimo
giro nel burro io o un'agenzia per
shampoo per capelli
posso andare a friggere vai
a disposizione se viene sentiri corda il
sapore chiaramente chiaramente mamma mia
ragazzi che ballano la mente o banelli
succo
bene anno di buffon che giorno è oggi il
9 gennaio lo scriveranno
senato tutto di gennaio
ora ci ho pensato
che ascanio chi mike jackson
ragazzi prima di assaggiare questo
orrore vi invito iscrivetevi a questo
canale perché veramente oggi sto
faticando metterci un bel like e
lasciarci un commento facendoci sapere
quali sono altri esperimenti culinari
magari presidiano web che vorreste
vederci creare
d'orazio
non è
disgustoso è una bomba c'erano semplice
pesante questa è la cosa più pesante qui
abbiamo mai mangiato in tutta la mia
vita
dagli un bel morso accordo di casa
il pane motore canterò
meglio
è squisito provato accadono
giammarco no
è sconcertante è già sulla lista questa
ruota di del tuo tempo perché no no no
preferisco mandarlo giù prima di
pensarci
una delle cose più disgustose mai viste
sul pianeta pensavo fosse la banana la
cosa pi nome ma passa così in sordina è
il burro d'arachidi secondo me lo faceva
meglio a me lo speravo perché cavoli di
questi temi era perché almeno ti stende
va subito
penso mi avete stomacato per per il mese
di gennaio intero se sei un cliente di
graziana è vero che bush
ricordiamo a tutti insieme alla croce
bush che cos'è all fratini aa bike
andata bravissimo immangiabile
a te piace elvis non
aprì a
magara borso prima che potesse nel
terribile la merda dai sono contento
averlo condiviso con te grazie ora
ricordo il motivo per cui mi piacque
questo panino
esattamente perché
e come da una produzione da me avviata
nel 2000
ci si vede ragazzi
questa sera abbiamo visto tutti un video
bellissimo vicente iscritti al canale è
attivato la campanella ok il pari era
buonissimo
ragazzi mi vado a medicare grazie per
aver visto questo video enrico grazie ti
prego parti per l'america
questo video è questo video è finito
ragazzi ci vediamo domenica però siamo
rock rimpatri che ce l'ha portata alle
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]